I think we're all in one very basic game
which is the attention graph where are
people's attention are you able to find
where that is welcome my good friend
Gary Vaynerchuk we're waiting for a
couple of years for Gary to come we
finally got him he's got a lot of super
fans out there what gets results is
attention it's all depth not width and
what snapchat was was and still to this
moment we're really paying attention
right now when you look at the attention
graph that I most care about instagrams
got it everybody here is much more
selective of who they follow on
Instagram they're actually consuming
those things it's not as want to file a
quality point where people consuming it
it's massively important people break up
into black or white camp data everybody
in that friction of the smart people in
this room that understand the data and
the dumb people in corporate America
right who are only into how does it make
me feel and I'm just such a big fan that
the magic happens in the gray there's a
middle ground where all the [ __ ]
magic